[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهده في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من النيمي عاصمه النيجر تهديد
بمحاكمه الرئيس المحتجز محمد بازون بتهمه
الخيانه العظمى اثار انتقادات دوليه
واقليبيه
الى الخرطوم ومعارك تتصاعد بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في مناطق
متفرقه من العاصمه ومدنها الثلاث وخارجهم
ايضا
الى هوايا التي رجح حاكمها عثورا طواقي من
انقاذ على عشر جثث الى عشرين جثه يوميا ما
يعني ان حصيله حرائق الغابات الاكثر فتكا
منذ اكثر من قرن في الولايات المتحده قد
ترتفع
في عناوين حصاد
بعد اعلان قاده انقلاب النيجر عزمه محاكمه
الرئيس المحتجس انتقادات اقليميه ودوليه
تصف الخطوه بالاستفزازيه قلق امامي
واواشنطن تعتبر بزوم الرئيس الشرعي وتطالب
باطلاق سراحه وتشدد على استعاده النظام
الدستوري وفي ادس ابابا مجلس السلم والامن
الافريقي يخفق في اتخاذ قرار بشان الازمه
على وقع معارك متنقله بين الخرطوم
وكوردوفان وجنوب دارفور البرهان يتهم
حميدتي بارتكاب جرائم حرب والامم المتحده
تقول ان نحو 20 الف شخص نزحوا جراء
الاشتباكات في نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب
دارفور
حرب مسيرات تتسع كيف تقول انها تصدت لهجوم
على اوديسا وموسكو تعلن احباط هجوم على
الارض معارك متواصله في الشرق والجنوب
الاوكراني وفي واشنطن الاعلان عن حزمه
مساعدات امنيه جديده لاوكرانيا ب 200
مليون دولار
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا المسارات المحتمله للازمه
في النيجر بعد اعلان قاده الانقلاب عزمه
محكمه الرئيس المحتجز محمد بازوم بتهمتي
الخيانه العظمى والمس بالامن وهي خطوه
وصفتها مجموعه اكواس بالاستفزازيه
الاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي في رايكم الى اين
تتجه مسارات وسيناريوهات الازمه في النيجر
جاءت الاجابات كالتالي نحو 34% توقعوا
تصعيدا في الازمه واحتمال تدخل عسكري
قرابه 27% راوا ان الازمه تتجه الى تهدئه
وحل دبلوماسي محتمل بينما اختار حوالي 39%
احتماليه استمرار سجال الازمه دون تغيير
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوريا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
ضمن برنامج للقصه بقيه على شاشه الجزيره
تحقيق خاص يتتبع شبكات صناعه المخدرات في
افغانستان
[موسيقى]
اعلن قاده الانقلاب في النيجر عزمهم مقاده
الرئيس المحتز محمد بازوم بتهمه الخيانه
العظمى على خلفيه تعاملات له مع زعماء دول
اجنبيه ومنظمات دوليه خطوه اعتبرتها الامم
المتحده مقلقه للغايه ووصفتها المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا اكواس
بالاستفزازيه وفي ادسرب اخفق مجلس السلم
والامن الافريقي في اتخاذ قرار بشان تعليق
عضويه النيجر في الاتحاد الافريقي
للانقلاب هنا لحن وكلمات
المحتفون في النيجر باطاحه رئيسهم لا
يسالون عن مصيره
اما المنقلبون عليه فلا يكتفون بالعزل
والاحتجاز انهم يتاهبون لمحاكمه الرئيس
محمد بازوم بما ثقل من التهامي
جماعه حكومه النيجر العناصر الضروريه
للاثباتات لكي تتابع امام الهيئات الوطنيه
والدوليه المؤهله الرئيس المتاح به
وشركائه في الداخل والخارج بتهمتي الخيانه
العظمى والمس بامن النيجر في الداخل
والخارج بعد اتصالاته بمواطنين وبرؤساء
دول اجنبيه ومسؤولين في منظمات دوليه
ترفض المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غربيه
افريقيا اكواس توجيه تهمه الخيانه العظمى
لرئيس النيجر المحتجز وتصف الخطوه
بالاستفزازيه لا يعلق قاده الانقلاب
يفضلون الاشاره الى وضع الرئيس الصحي الذي
يصفونه بالجيد ويقولون انه الموقوفين
يعاملون وفق قوانين حقوق الانسان يبدو
انها رساله الى الداخل والخارج هذه رساله
من نوع اخر تتجاوز حدود البلد لكنها تخص
مصيره
لسانسبي يدين المجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن
والحكومه الانتقاليه الحمله المضلله التي
تخدم مصلحه شخص واحد وتخدم جماعته الهدف
من الحمله هو تقويض الثقه في السلطات
الانتقاليه وافشال جميع مسائل حل التفاوضي
للخروج من الازمه لتبرير تدخل عسكري او
كلا رؤساء بعض الدول تنفيذه الى قوه دوليه
باسم اكواس
لا باس اذا بالحوار مع اكواس فرئيس
الوزراء الذي عينه المجلس العسكري الحاكم
في النيجر يكشف ان قائد المجلس اعطى الضوء
الاخضر لبدء المحادثات مع المجموعه
والمجموعه قرر برلمانها ارسال لجنه الى
تبحث مع قاده الانقلاب سبل انهاء الازمه
دبلوماسيا ربما زالت الان موانع التفاوض
في النيجر غير ان الخيارات الافريقيه في
التعامل مع الوضع الجديد في هذا البلد ما
زالت مفتوحه المشكله ان التحرك العسكريه
حوله خلاف حاد هو ذاته الذي عطل التوافق
في اجتماع مجلس الامن والسلم الافريقي على
تعليق عضويه في الاتحاد الافريقي
كما طفت التباينات خلال اجتماع اديس ابابا
حول اي السبل انجح في النيجر الحل
الدبلوماسي ام التدخل العسكري
قد يسجلها المنقلبون على سلطه الرئيس
بازوم نقطه لمصلحتهم لكن هذه ليست اخر
تحدياتهم والحكومه الانتقاليه التي شكلوها
فعاد عن اشكاليه الشرعيه والاعتراف تزيد
العقوبات التي تنهال على البلد منذ
الانقلاب منها هشاشه الاوضاع على الجبهتين
الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه وتزداد بذلك
التحديات التي تواجه قاده الانقلاب في
النيجر انهم يصفون العقوبات بانها تحد غير
منصف يعيدون بتجاوزه
هذا وقال رئيس الوزراء المعين في النيجر
محمد الامين الزين ان رئيس المجلس العسكري
الحاكم عبد الرحمن تياني اعطى الضوء
الاخضر لبدء المحادثات مع مجموعه اكواس
واعرب الامين الزين عن تفائله ببدء هذه
المحادثات مع المجموعه خلال الايام
القادمه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انه اجرى
اتصالا هاتفيا مع رئيس نيجيريا بحث خلاله
الجهود المشتركه لاستعاده النظام الدستوري
في النيجر جاته قال نائب المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان مقضاه محمد بازون
الذي وصفه بالرئيس الشرعي عمل غير مبرر
ولن تساهم في حل سلمي للاسما
سنعود الى موضوع الانقلاب في النيجر لاحقا
نتحول الان الى الملف السوداني حيث اتهم
رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد الفتاح
البرهان قوات الدعم السريع بالغدر وشهدت
العاصمه الخرطوم وجنوب دارفور وغرب كردفان
مواجهات عسكريه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وشهد جنوب كردفان مواجهات بين قوات
الجيش وقوات الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير
السودان شمال جناح عبد العزيز الحلو
تتمدد رقعه المواجهات العسكريه في السودان
مع مرور الوقت ولا يلوح في الافق امل في
توقفها قريبا
في هذه الاجواء يحتفل الجيش السوداني
بعيده الوطني الثامن وستين ويتهم قائده
قوات الدعم السريع بالغطا بلادنا تواجه
اكبر مؤامره في تاريخها الحديث
تستهدف كيان وهويه وتراث مصير شعبنا الذي
ظل منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي
يواجه بالصبر وايمان ابشع فصول الارهاب
على ايدي مليجي المتمرد الخائن حميدتي
واعوانه الذين قادوا اكبر ظاهره قامت على
التضليل والكذب والخداع وتزييف الحقائق
وشيرازي وما الناس في تاريخ هذا البلد تحت
لافته ورايه زيف مؤسسه تسمى بالدعم السريع
قبل اي من دعى قائد قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان حميتي الى رفض التفاوض مع قاده
الجيش الذين طالبهم بالتنحي تنم هذه
تصريحات عن مستوى عدم الثقه بين الطرفين
ذلك على ارض الواقع في نياله عاصمه جنوب
دارفور دارت معارك عنيفه وقال مصدر للجيش
السوداني ان قوات الجيش صدت هجوما لقوات
الدعم السريع على مقر الفرقه السادسه عشره
في اقليم كردفان يشارك طرف ثالث في
المعادله العسكريه دارت مواجهات بعد ان
هاجمت قوات الحركه الشعبيه الشمال جنى عبد
العزيز الحلو حاميه عسكريه استراتيجيه
تابعه للجيش هذه ليست المواجهات الاولى
فقد فتح قائد الحركه جبهه اخرى امام الجيش
وهو الذي رفض توقيع اتفاق جوبا مع الحكومه
الانتقاليه وحركات مسلحه عام 2020 لوقع
معها لاحقا اتفاقا لوقف اطلاق النار في
غرب كردفان قالت مصادر محليه ان قوات
الدعم السريع استولت على اسلحه قسم للشرطه
المحليه والشبكه مع السكان المحليين
امتداد المواجهات لدارفور وكوردوفان لم
يخفف من احتدامها في العاصمه الخرطوم حيث
شهدت ام درمان قصفا متبادلا بين الجيش
والدعم السريع دخان المعارك هنا يخفي
ماساه انسانيه تتفاقم حسب مشروع تجميع
البيانات في مناطق الصراع المسلح قتل 3900
سوداني منذ اندلاع المواجهات وتقدر ارقام
الامم المتحده عدد النازحين داخل البلاد
باكثر من ثلاثه ملايين سوداني اما عدد من
لجاوا الى دول الجوار فيقترب من المليون
كما يقترب عدد السودانيين الذين يحتاجون
مساعده من 25 مليونا وتقول منظمه اطباء
بلا حدود ان ثلاثه ارباع مستشفيات البلاد
اصبحت خارج الخدمه هي ارقام تشير الى هول
الكارثه التي حلت بالسودانيين
اعود الى ملف النيجر واعلام قاده الانقلاب
عزمهم مقاضاه الرئيس المحتجز محمد بازومي
الدار البيضاء عمر عبد الرحمن رئيس حزب
اتحاد الوطني الافارقه المعارض في النيجر
سيد عبد الرحمن ماذا نفهم من توقيت
الاعلان عن مقاضاه الرئيس بازون من قبل
قاده الانقلاب
اود ان اشكركم على هذه الفرصه التي
اعطيتموها لكي اعبر عن رايي بالنسبه الى
الوضع في النعجه بالنسبه الى التوقيت مما
لا شك فيه ان الرغبه الشعبيه والضغوط
الشعبيه هي التي فرضت التوقيت حيث ان
الشعب الشعب النيجيري اليوم يمكنه ان
يتاكد
يستعيد الثقه بما يقوم به العسكريون
بالنسبه الى الوضع الراهن في النيجر
وشاهدنا ما حصل مع الرئيس بازوم
والرئيس بازون كان يخاطب وسائل الاعلام
الدوليه ويقول ان الارهابيين اقوى من قوات
الدفاع والامن ويجب ان نفهم ان العسكريين
ايضا لم يتقبلوا هذا الامر واليوم
يستفيدون من هذه اللحظه السانحه
لكي يتخذوا هذه الخطوات وما سرع هذه
الخطوه كذلك هو ما حصل في الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه
والايام الماضيه المقربون من الرئيس بازون
والرئيس بازون بنفسه مع
قام به من خلال الواشنطن بوست لقد طلب
مساعده غربيه وطلب من اصدقائي اصدقائي
العسكريين هذا التوجه من قاده الانقلاب
اثار حفيظه المجتمع الدولي والقضاء
الافارقه يقولون بانه استفزاز من قبل قاده
الانقلاب للديمقراطيه والحياه الد ستوريه
في النيجر وفي افريقيا عموما كيف تفهمون
هذه المواقف حتى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قبل قليل بموقف للخارجيه
الامريكيه قالت بان هذا مرفوض وهو مستفز
للديمقراطيه والدستوريه في النيجر
نعم بالفعل ان المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول
غرب افريقيا تؤدي دورها الا وهو ان تتودد
الى القوى العظمى ووزير الخارجيه الفرنسي
كان في النيجر بعد
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بشهرين
المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا لم
تعبر عن اي راي بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
تدخلات
شاهدناها في الانتخابات والنتائج لم تكن
شفافه ولكن المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا لم تقم بشيء ان القاده في النيجر
يصغون الى الشعب
ويودون ان يقوموا بما هو جيد بالنسبه الى
شاب ولا يتعينوا على المجموعه الاقتصاديه
ادويه غربي افريقيا ان تملي ذلك على الشعب
المسار الذي يسلكه الان قاده الانقلاب في
النيجر هل يوحي ويبدو لك بانهم عازمون على
مرحله انتقاليه يسلمون بعدها السلطه لسلطه
مدنيه منتخبه
في الحقيقه في الفتره الراهنه المشكله
الحقيقيه التي يعاني منها الشعب في النيجر
اليوم هو انعدام الامن هناك قتل
العسكريين
ورئيس او القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
الا وهو السيد محمد بازوم الرئيس السابق
تحدث وقال ان الارهابيين اقوى لذلك اعتقد
انه من الطبيعي ان نشهد هذا الرد من
العسكريين الان ليس الاوان لكي نتحدث عن
المرحله الانتقاليه ولا الى الانتقال
المدني
للمدنيين المساله الجوهريه الان هي في
ارساء الامن والسلام في بلادنا بالاضافه
الى وقف
هذه
الارتكابات التي استمرت لفتره طويله من
فساد وغيرها في خلال عهده
الذي لم يتمكن من مواجهه الفساد في البلاد
بالرغم من الوعود اذا كل الشعب في النيجر
خرج الى الطرقات
لكي يدعم هذه الخطوه ليس فقط لتغيير الشخص
على في سده الرئاسه بل لان الشعب يود ان
يرى بلدا ليس في سيطره للارهابيين وايضا
في الوقت نفسه
الفساد عمر عبد الرحمن رئيس حزب اتحاد
الوطنيين الافارقه المعارض في النيجر شكرا
لك اذا اعود واذكر بان قاده الانقلاب في
النيجر اعلنوا عزمهم مقاضاه الرئيس
المحتجز محمد بازون على خلفيه ما يقولون
بانها تعاملات له مع زعماء دول اجنبيه
ومنظمات دوليه كما اسلفت هذه الخطوه راها
الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
وجميع المؤس سات الافريقيه بانها خطوه
استفزازيه على كل حال من اليمين ينضم
الينا
الحسن المستشار السياسي لرئيس النيجر
المحتجز محمد بازون
ما ردكم على هذه الاتهامات اتهامات
بالخيانه العظمى من قاده الانقلاب للرئيس
المحتجز محمد بازون ما ردكم على هذه
الاتهامات
طيب ساعيد طرح السؤال عليك مره جديده اذا
قاده الانقلابيين يعتزمون مقاضاه الرئيس
المحتجز محمد بازوم بتهمه الخيانه العظمى
ما ردكم على هذه الاتهامات
مع الاسف لدينا مشكله في الاتصال مع السيد
انتينيكا الحسن في النيجر سنحاول ان نعود
اليه وهو مستشار الرئيس محمد بازومي لنسمع
رايه وكيف يردون على هذه الاتهامات التي
وجهت من قبل قاده الانقلاب للرئيس محمد
بازون في نفس الموضوع تنضم الينا من
ميريلاند السيده بيزا ويليامز السفيره
الامريكيه السابقه في النيجر ونائبه مساعد
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق للشؤون
الافريقيه السفيره ويليامز كيف ترى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مسار قاده
الانقلاب حتى الان وصولا الى اعلانهم
عزمهم مقاضاه الرئيس سمعنا موقف من انتون
بلان وزير الخارجيه قبل قليل بان هذا هو
استفزاز وليس لمصلحه الحل السلمي في
النيجر ما هي الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
للتعامل مع هذه الخطوات المتسارعه من قاده
الانق
بدايه شكرا على دعوتي لديكم وعلي ان اؤكد
على رغم انني كنت ضمن الحكومه الامريكيه
لكنني لست
لم اعد كذلك بالتالي يجب طرح هذه الاسئله
على موظف حكوميه في الحكومه الامريكيه اذا
سالتوني بشكل شخصي اعتقد ان الولايه حكومه
الولايات المتحده جدي للغايه في مساله
مراجعه
نوعا من ايجاد نوع من الحوار مع المجلس
العسكري لكن هذه التصريحات من الوزير
بلينكن تشير الى ان المجلس الحاكم العسكري
يرتكب اخطاء ان خطيره بزعمهم انهم ينوون
محاكمه الرئيس بازون الوزير بلين قال ان
هذا الامر سيكون خطوه الى الوراء وايضا
اعتقد ان سيكون من الصعب جدا على الولايات
المتحده ان تحاول تبا لجهودها من اجل ان
تجد حلا سلميا لهذه الا للتاكيد سيده فيزا
نحن نستضيفك
كشخصيه
وليس كممثله للحكومه الامريكيه او مسؤوله
بالحكومه الامريكيه فقط للتاكيد
هذه المواقف المتضاربه من المؤسسات
الافريقيه والانقسام الذي الذي يبرز الان
حول طبيعه التدخل وكيفيه التدخل لعوده
الحياه
الديمقراطيه والدستوريه في النيجر ما
الاشارات التي ترسلها للمجتمع الدولي
وايضا لقاده الانقلاب في النيجر بتقديرك
اعتقد ان
لفتره طويله فان الرئيس
زوم كان
رهينه لهذه القوه التي قامت بالانقلاب وهو
هذا الامر يرسل مؤشرات غير واضحه الى
الجميع الى الاكواز والى الولايات المتحده
والى جميع امان يدعم النيجر على الرغم من
انني لن اقول ان
مواقع الموقع
موقف الاكواس واضح وحسب ميثاقها فان هذه
هذه المنظمه لا تدعم الانقلابات وستدعم
الحكومه والحكومه المنتخبه الديمقراطيا
والولايات المتحده قالت بشكل واضح ايضا
انها تدعم موقف الاكواس لكن كيف كيف هو
ربما هي التي تسبب بعض الانقسام وهذا ما
يعطي المجلس الحاكم العسكري مجانا للتنفس
والتحريك لكنه يربك هذا المجلس اذا ان
الاعلان اعلان انهم انهم سيقومون
بتوجيه تهمه
رئيس المنتخب في الوقت الذي هم قاموا بخلق
القانون يظهروا انهم يشعرون بالرعب الان
في حال استمر هذا المجلس وقاده الانقلاب
في التنفس كما كما قلت بسبب هذه الاشارات
المتضاربه وبالفعل قاد وحاكم الرئيس محمد
بازوبي تهمه الخيانه العظمى في ظل هذا
الشلل الحاصل الافريقيا هل ممكن
لموقف المجتمع الدولي ان يتغير تجاه تدخل
ما سياسي او ابعد من ذلك في النيجر
بتقديرك
اعتقد انه حسب شعوري فان هذا الامر سيعطي
الزخما اكثر الى التدخل نحو التدخل
العسكري كما قلت فان اذا ما قرر واستمر
المجلس العسكري بمساله محاكمه الرئيس
السابق زوم هذا يظهر انهم يشعرون بالذعر
ما يمثله الرئيس لانهم يعرفون انه كان
رئيسا بشكل ديمقراطي وكان مخلصا لكنني
اعتقد ايضا ان المجتمع الدولي لا يمكن ان
يتحمل هذا الامر طبعا انت شكرا لك شكرا
السفيره بيزا ويليامز السفير امريكيه
السابقه في النيجر نائبه مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي السابق للشؤون
الافريقيه سنعود مره جديده الى ضيفنا في
نياميه
انتينيكار الحسن المستشار السياسي للرئيس
النيجر المحتجز محمد بزوم على امل ان يكون
يسمعني الان
ساعيد عليك طرح السؤال
قاده الانقلاب يعتزمون محاكمه ومقاداه
الرئيس المحتجز محمد باسوم بتهمه الخيانه
العظمى ما ردكم على هذه التهم
ميرسي بوكوني شكرا جزيلا على هذه الفرصه
في البيان السبعه والعشرين كان هناك اشاره
الى وضع الرئيس بازوم محمد
وانها اللحظه
نحن نسمعك تابع لو سمحت
نحن نسمعك جيدا سيد الحسن
سيد الحسن
نحن نسمعك تابع لو سمحت
طبعا بسبب الوضع الحاصل في النيجر هناك
مشكله في
التواصل مع الضيوف في انمي عاصمه نيجيريا
انتنيكار الحسن هو مستشار سياسي للرئيس
محمد بازوم الذي اعلن قاده الانقلاب عزمهم
مقاضاته بتهم منها تهمه الخيانه العظمى
لما يقولون بانه
علاقه وتعاملات لمحمد بازوم مع دول اجنبيه
ومنظمات دوليه نعمل على اعاده الاتصال مع
السيد الحسن سيد الحسن نحن نسمعك الان
تابع لو سمحت
الو نسمعك تابع
نعم اذا بالنسبه
الينا كنت اقول ان هذه التهم بالخيانه
العظمى فاجاتنا لانه بحسب علمنا نحن نتحدث
عن رئيس في سته الرئاسه اذا بحسب فهمي
الرئيس محمد بازوم لا يزال رئيس الجمهوريه
في النيجر طيب شكرا لك السيد الحسن
المستشار السياسي رئيس النيجر المحتجز
محمد بازوم في نيام في النيجر شكرا لك
نعود اذن الى الملف السوداني فقط قال
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
ستيفاندو شاريك ان مكتبه تنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه اعرب عن قلقه العميق اذا اتى
تقارير تفيد بوقوع اشتباكات داميه في جنوب
دارفور في الايام الاخيره ديجيريك اضاف ان
العنف ادى الى نزوح نحو 20 الف شخص من عده
احياء في بلده نيالا
قالت مديره مكتب الوان المتحده لشؤون
الانسانيه في السودان فيكتوريا سيسز
ان اكثر من سته ملايين سوداني يعانون
حاليا من الجوع وحذرت في مقابله مع
الجزيره من ان من يعيشون في السودان حاليا
يعانون من ظروف بالغه الصعوبه وانه من
الخطر انتظار اعلان حاله المجاعه للتدخل
الحقيقي بحسب تعبيرها
السودان يمكننا ان نصف الوضع الانساني في
السودان بانه كارثي هناك اربعه وعشرون
مليون شخص بحاجه طارئه للمساعدات
الانسانيه ونحن نعرف ان اكثر من اربعه
ملايين شخص نزحوا بالفعل وان اكثر من 190
الفا هربوا الى دول الجوار مثل مصر
واثيوبيا وتشاد ومن بقوا في البلاد او
يعيشون في مواقع النزوح يعانون من ظروف
صعبه للغايه الوضع مقلق جدا وحياه ملايين
الاشخاص في خطر سته ملايين و300 الف
سوداني حاليا يعانون من المجاعه اي انهم
يقومون ببيع ما يملكونه من اجل شراء
الغذاء وبانتظار الاعلان عن المجاعه بشكل
رسمي سيكون الوقت قد تاخر لمساعدتهم
اذا في الشق السياسيه اقعد اذكر بان السيد
البرهان رئيس مجلس السياده له خطاب وكلمه
واتهم فيها قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
حميدتي دقلو والدعم السريع بالغدر من
باريس سانضم الينا محمد طورشين الكاتب
والباحث السياسي السوداني سيد محمد ما
رسائل السيد البرهان في هذا الخطاب الذي
القاه
في البلد وكذلك المشاهدين الكرام
بلا شك الخطاب السيد البرهان انه جاء في
مناسبه ورسميه بمناسبه سودنه القياده
القوات المسلحه السودانيه الا انه لم
يخلوا من الرسائل السياسيه بالرغم ان في
الاتجاه المعارك التي تجري بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع منذ الخامس عشر من
ابريل حتى يومنا هذا ظل الخطاب في تقدير
المرتبط بالخيار الحسن العسكري بالرغم انه
لم يشير الى ذلك صراحه وفي الاتجاه الاخر
انا اعتقد انه ارسل رسائل للقيارات
العسكريه للدعم السريع بانه يمكن ان تكون
هنالك التفاهمات بينه وبين القوات المسلحه
اذا تم ابعاد محمد حمدان دقلو وشقيقه من
قياده القوات الدعم السريع انا في تقدير
الاشاره المهمه متمثله في انه ارسال رسائل
للقوس سياسيه بان القوات المسلحه عازمه في
الاستمرار في مسار الانتقال المدني
الديمقراطي انتهاء بانتخابات حره
ودممقراطيه يشارك فيها كل من الشعب
السوداني ودعا بشكل او باخر ربما تكون
هنالك مباحثات قبل انتهاء هذه المعارك
سلما او حربا او بعدها باطار مباحثات في
اطار تفاوض لايجاد صيغه جديده هذا يعني
بان كل الذي كان من قبل ربما انتهى ونحن
في اطار مرحله جديده في اطار مباحثات
وصيغه جديده لاستكمال ما تبقى من الفتره
الانتقاليه وانا في تقديري ارساله رساله
لقوه السياسيه بان كل ما مضى قبل تاريخ 15
ابريل بمعنى ان هنالك صفحه جديده هنالك
ربما تقديم بعض الضمانات للقوى السياسيه
بان القوات المسلحه وكذلك البرهان تكون
هنالك جديده
غياب اي اشاره من السيد البرهان
للتفاوض او الحوار مع الدعم السريع لوقف
الحرب والاقتتال الى ماذا تؤشر هل هذا
يعني بان الجيش
اتخذ قراره في هذه المرحله بالحسم
العسكريا
هو بلا شك حتى الان انا اقرا خطاب السيد
البرهان مغرورا بخطاب السيد محمد حمدان
دغلول الاخير باعتبار انه هنالك تصعيد
وهنالك الرغبه جامحه من قبل طرفيه الصرع
بان تكون الحسم العسكري هو الخيار الامثل
الوحيد بالرغم من ان هنالك مباحثات في جده
حتى الان المعلومات حولها شحيحه جدا او
شبه معدومه وبعد مغادره وفد الجيش جده
واصوله الى السودان لكن باي حال من
الاحوال كل طرف يفضل الخيار العسكري لماذا
تفضيل الخ
يار لانه من تستطيع ان تفرط اجندتك
التفاوضيه ومشروعك ورؤيتك السياسيه لاسيما
بان في هذه الحاله اذا استجاب الجيش
السوداني لمبدا التفاوض والمباحثات
فيما يتعلق في مستقبل قوات الدعم السريعه
لا يتوقع انه لا يستطيع فرض شروط متوتره
في استمرار قياده الدعم السريع في المشهد
او ابعادها فضلا عن ذلك فيما يتعلق بقياده
اسيطر القوات الدعم السريعي في المقبل
الايام وكذلك القيد الزمن المرتبط بدمجه
في القوات المسلحه فبالتالي كل هذه الامور
لا يستطيع الطرف الا لم يكن منتظر فرض
رؤيته فيها الاذاعه على اتوقع انه الجيش
السوداني يزعم بشكله باخر وتحقيق انتصارات
سريع لو سمحت سيد محمد كان لافتا ان السيد
البرهان حملتي والدعم السريع مسؤوليه
بدء الحرب وما حصل بعدها وحتى حمله
مسؤوليه الفتره من بعد يعني الاطاحه
بالرئيس السابق عمر
البشير ما مدى واجهت هذا ان يتحمل حميتي
والدعم السريع مسؤوليه كل ما حصل ونحن
نعلم بان البرهان وحمتي كانوا شركاء في
هذه المرحله باقتضاض لو سمحت
هو بلا شك محمد حمدان دقله وكذلك البرهان
هم شركاء ويتحملون المسؤوليه الاخلاقيه
والسياسيه لهذه الحرب هي حال من الاحوال
وخطاب البرهان لتحميله محمد حمدان دبلي
كله ما حدثوا محاوله للتنصل من المسؤوليه
والتنقل من
السمح الذي من خلاله يستطاعله يتمدد
باعتبار انه لا يلقى الماده الخامسه من
قانون الدعم السريع لا اعتقد بان محمد
حمدان دقله يستطيع ان يتمدد كل هذه القدر
وبالتالي البرهان ينبغي باي حال من
الاحوال اذا استمرت هذه المعارك او توصلوا
الى ينبغي ان يستغل عنه ما حدث الان
يتحمله البرهان اكبر من محمد حمد
تورشين الكاتب والباحث السياسي في باريس
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اتابع مع تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث اعلنت الاداره الاقليميه العسكريه في
اوديسا ان القوات الروسيه هاجمت اوديسا
المطله على البحر الاسود ليلا بخمسه عشره
مسيره وثمانيه صواريخ كاليبر واضافت ان
ثلاثه اشخاص اصيبوا في الهجوم وتعتبر
اوديسا اكبر ميناء وقاعده بحريه في
اوكرانيا وتتعرض لهاجمات متكرره بالصواريخ
وطائرات المسيره بعد انسحاب روسيا في
يوليو الماضي من اتفاق كان يسمح بشحن
الحبوب من الموانئ الاوكرانيه
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها اسقطت
مسيره اوكرانيه حاولت شن هجوم على مقاطعه
واوضحت الوزاره في بيان انها احبطت محاوله
جديده لارتكاب ما وصفته بهجوم ارهابي
مشيره الى ان القوات الروسيه كشفت المسيره
ودمرتها فوق اراضي المقاطعه دون اصابات او
اضرار ماديه في المقابل اعلنت القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه اسقطت طائره مروحيه
روسيه من طراز كي 52 شرق البلاد
قال المستشار في مكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ميخائيل بولاك ان اي تصريحات حول التقدم
البطيء للجيش الاوكراني هو دليل على
الافتقار المطلق لفهم الحرب واضاف ان مهمه
القوات الاوكرانيه تتمثل بتدمير منهجي
لقدرات الجيش الروسي بالتوازي اعلنت روسيا
ان غواصه جديده تعمل بالوقود النووي ستدخل
الخدمه خلال العام الحالي وهي مجهزه لحمل
صواريخ زيركون الفرد صوتيه تفاصيل
استراتيجيات روسيا واوكرانيا في القتال
متابعها في التقرير التالي
لم تعد المنطقه الحدوديه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا امنه تماما الجانب الروسي من
الحدود يبقى في مرمى المسيرات الاوكرانيه
بالكرات تحديدا تتعرض لهجمات بشكل شبهي
يومي غالبا ما تكون الاضرار الناتجه عن
هذه الاستهدافات محدوده حتى تلك التي تصل
العاصمه موسكو لكنها دون شك تنقل رساله من
كييف مفادها ان ضرب العمق الروسي لم يعد
مساله مستحيله وهذا ما يقلق روسيا
فالقدرات الهجوميه الاوكرانيه تدفع موسكو
الى تكثيف الاستعداد
لمواجهه هذه الضربات المركز الروسي
استراتيجي نشر تقريرا يكشف ان روسيا انشات
حقل رادار للدفاع الجوي في الاتجاه الغربي
من البلاد منذ مده طويله مهمته رصد
الاهداف التي تحلق على ارتفاعات منخفضه
الصغيره كالمسيرات ونقل تقرير المركز عن
متخصصين ان الرادار الحديث يمكنه اكتشاف
الطائرات القادره على التخفي على مسافه
ثلاثه الاف كيلومتر واكتشاف عمليات اطلاق
صواريخ كروز او الطائرات التي تفوق سرعتها
سرعه الصوت على مسافه تبعد الفي كم عن
الحدود الروسيه على مستوى التسلح
استراتيجي كشف الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه
الروسيه لبناء السفن الاكس رخمه نوف ان
الغواصه النوويه متعدده الاغراض ارخان
جيرس سيتم اطلاقها خلال العام الحالي وهي
من فئه غواصات ياس ام التي تعمل بالوقود
النووي لتنضم الى ثلاث غواصات من الفئه
نفسها غواصات سيفيرو دافيناسك وكازان
ونوفو سايبر اسك وسيتم تزويد جميع هذه
الغواصات بصواريخ زيركون الفرط صوتيه وهي
صواريخ يصل مداها لنحو 900 كم ويمكن ان
تتجاوز سرعتها سرعه الصوت بعده اضعاف
لتشكل بالتالي تحديا كبيرا لامن الدول
بسبب قدرتها على المناوره وتجنب الدفاعات
الارضيه التقليديه في المقابل تستمر
اوكرانيا باعتماد استراتيجيه تستند على
استنزاف الجيش الروسي في نقاط تفوقه ضربات
بعيده المدى تستهدف بشكل خاص طرق الامداد
الروسيه والبنيه التحتيه للنقل العسكري
بالتوازي يقول المستشار في مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني ميخائيل كودولياك ان اي تصريحات
حول التقدم البطيء للجيش الاوكراني هي
دليل على الافتقار المطلق لفهم الحرب
ويضيف ان مهمه القوات الاوكرانيه تتمثل
بتدم ير منهجي لقدرات الجيش الروسي
[موسيقى]
في غضون ذلك اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
حزمه مساعدات امنيه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه
200 مليون دولار لكن اوضح ان هذه
المساعدات تتضمن ذخائر للدفاع الجوي
وطلقات المدفعيه ومعدات مضاده للدروع
وغيرها وقال بلنكن ان روسيا بدات هذه
الحرب ويمكن ان تنهيها في اي وقت بسحب
قواتها من اوكرانيا ووقف هجماتها الوحشيه
وفق تعبيره واضاف ان الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها وشركائها سيقفون متحدين مع
اوكرانيا مهما طال الامر الى ان توقف
روسيا حربها جانبها قالت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ان حزمه المساعدات الجديده التي
ستسحب من مخزون الوزاره تشمل ذخيره
لمنظومه الدفاع الجوي وراجمات هاي مارس
بالاضافه الى قذائفه لمدفعيه الميدان
والدبابات وصواريخ مضاده للمدرعات من
طرازي تاو وجافلين
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نستعرض خطوط
المعركه بين الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني
ونسال ضيف الحصاد عن استراتيجيه وتكتيكات
الطرفين
ارتفعت حصيله ضحايا حرائق الغابات فيها
واي الى نحو 100 قتيل لتصبح بذلك اكثر
الحرائق دمويه في الولايات المتحده منذ
اكثر من قرن ووفقا للتقديرات الرسميه فقد
دمرت الحرائق اكثر من 2200 مبدا ما تسبب
في تشريد الالاف واوقع خسائر ماديه تجاوزت
خمسه مليارات دولار ونصف المليار واطلقت
سلطتها واي تحقيقا بشان طريقه التعامل مع
الحرائق بعدما اكد السكان عدم تلقيهم اي
تحذيرات
محمد العلمي ينضم اين من هاواي محمد ما
ابرز التحديات الان امام السلطات المحليه
في هذه المرحله
تحديات متعدده لكن ربما من ابرزها اولا
العثور على القتلى
وتحديد هويتهم وذلك سيكون صعبا للغايه
بحكم ان الحراره المرتفعه حولت جدتهم الى
رماد
وهناك محاوله
لجمع نماذج وعينات من الحمض النووي
لاقاربهم من اجل مطابقتها مما يستخرج من
الجثث
وحتى حاكم الولايه يتوقع ان يرتفع رقم
الضحايا بشكل كبير كلما واصل عمال البحث
والتنقيب البحث عن الضحايا سواء في
الشوارع او في السيارات او في منازلهم
التحدي الاخر هو تعامل مع الالاف الذين
اصبحوا مشردين هذه الولايه التي تعتمد
بشكل كبير على السياحه نصحت السائحين
الراغبين في القدوم الى ولايه الى جزيره
ماوي كبرى جزر الارخبيل ان يغيروا من
برامجهم وحتى المقيمين ان يغادروا ان امكن
ذلك
حتى
يتسنى استخدام غرف الفنادق والبيوت من اجل
ايواء هؤلاء الذين يحتاجون الى ماوى بشكل
عاجل حتى سكان البلده المنكوبه منعوا من
الدخول الى الى تلك البلده المطوقه
والمغلقه تماما
الى ان تنتهي عمليه البحث عن المفقودين
والضحايا وايضا للحيلوله دون عبث الناس
بما بقي من تلك البلده التي دمرت عن اخرها
هناك تحقيقات بدات لماذا كل هذا العدد
الهائل من الضحايا ومن الدمار
وهناك تسليط وتاكيد على ان ربما
وكاله الوكاله التي توفر خدمات كهرباء
مسؤوله على الاقل في نظر اعين الناس لانها
لم تقطع خدمات الكهرباء في وجه رياح عاتيه
اسقطت الكثير شكرا للكهربائي ارضا مما
ساهم في اشعاله الحريق شكرا لك يا محمد في
هاواي
برنامج للقصه بقيه مراكز زراعه الافيون
وشبكات تهريبه ومعامل صناعه المخدرات التي
تبقي تجاره المخدرات قائمه في افغانستان
رغم الحظر الذي فرضته طالبان على زراعه
وتجاره الافيون منذ ابريل 2022 ووفق
البرنامج شهادات تجاري ومهربي مخدرات
كشفوا استراتيجيات التهريب
هنا وبين محاصيل الخشخاش رافق برنامج
للقصه بقيه قوات مكافحه المخدرات التابعه
للطالبان في حملاتها لاتلاف الافيون في
البلد الذي ينتج ما يعادل 80% من الانتاج
العالمي غير المشروع للافيون وفق مكتب
الامم المتحده للمخدرات والجريمه رغم
الحظر الذي فرضته طالبان على زراعه وتجاره
الافيون منذ ابريل 2022
للقصه بقيه تقسم مراكز زراعه الافيون
وشبكات تهريبه ومعامل صناعه المخدرات التي
تبقي تجارتها قائمه في افغانستان من
افغانستان حيث يتم تحميل المخدرات قد
تستلم الشحنه 50 يدا الى ان تصل الى
مالكها الرئيسي لدينا موظفون في كل منطقه
فمثلا لديه انا في بلوشستان
وانا انظم كل شيء
كالمسلحين والمرشدين هل تعتقد ان من يهرب
طنا من المخدرات سيفعل ذلك بالاهتمام ودون
اي تفكير ايا كان من يهربها فهو يعرض
حياته للخطر
هو يوظف مضحين مسلحين كي لا تضيع ثلاثه او
اربعه ملايين دولار هباء
تصنع هذه المخدرات بادوات بدائيه داخل
معامل سريه تقليديه في المناطق النائيه
استطاع برنامج للقصه بقيه رصد نشاط احد
معامل صناعه الهيروين جنوبيه افغانستان
حيث يتطلب انتاج كيلوغرام واحد من
الهيروين حوالي 29 كلغ من مستخلص الافيون
مع مركبات كيميائيه لانتاج المورفين
لتتحول بعد بضع ساعات الى الهيروين زياده
القيود على مستخلصات الافيون تعني
ارتفاعها مش ارباحنا هنا نشتري الكيلو
جرام الواحد من الهيروين ب 2600 او 2800
دولار نشن عمليات تستهدف مصانع المخدرات
في افغانستان اعتقلنا 7000 مشتبه بتهريب
المخدرات دمرنا 600 مصنع لانتاج المخدرات
ودمرنا 11 الف هكتار من حقول الخشخاش كما
عالجنا 90000 من مدم نين المخدرات هذا
العام
بوتيره بطيئه تحل حقول القمح الذهبيه محل
محاصيل الخشخاش رغم ضعف مردودها الربحي
للمزارعين الا ان منظمه الفاو تعد بدعم
حوالي مليونين ومئه الف افغاني بمشاريع
انتاج القمح التي يرعاها البنك الدولي مع
نهايه نوفمبر 2023
على جبهات متعدده يستمر القتال بين
الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني دون تحقيق ما
يمكن وصفه بالانجاز العسكري الحاسم فكيف
تبدو خطوط المعركه في الشرق الاوكراني
تتواصل المعركه منذ عام للسيطره على مدينه
باخموت وتقول كياف انها استعادت السيطره
حتى الان على اربعين كيلو مترا مربعا
بالخاصره الجنوبيه لمحيط المدينه نبقى في
الشرق تقول موسكو انها صدت هجمات في منطقه
كوبيانسك بعد ان اعلنت تحقيق مكاسب
الاسبوع الماضي ودفعت السلطات الاوكرانيه
الى اصدار اوامر باخلاء عشرات البلدات الى
اجابه الجنوبيه حيث تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه منذ اسابيع رصد نقاط ضعف في
خطوط الدفاع الروسيه المحصنه بحقول الغام
وخنادق وحواجز مضاده للدبابات والعنوان
البارز هنا في الجنوب هي خرسون دون تفاصيل
تكشف كييف عن عمليات لبعض الوحدات
الاوكرانيه على الضفه الشرقيه لنهر
النيبرو وذلك بعد يوم من قصف روسي على
خرسون تقول انه اسفر عن مقتل واصابه عدد
من المدنيين الى البحر الاسود وجبهه
مواجهه اخرى حيث اعلنت قياده العمليات
الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه تعرض اوديس على البحر
الاسود الليله الماضيه لهجوم بواسطه 15
مسيره وثمانيه صواريخ من طراز كاليبر
جاتها اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
دمرت خلال الليل موقع بناء مسيرات بحريه
استخدمتها اوكرانيا لضرب الاصول الروسي في
البحر الاسود بدون تقديم تفاصيل اضافيه
هذه المعارك تاتي في ظل هجوم مضاد واسع
النطاق اطلقته اوكرانيا في يونيو الماضي
مدعومه طبعا بمساعده عسكريه غربيه بهدف
استعاده مناطق سيطرت عليها القوات الروسيه
فما الذي تحق
يصرح القاده الاوكرانيون باستمرار ان
المعارك صعبه وغير ان القوات بدات تحقق
نتائج مطالبينا بمزيد من الاسلحه لا سيما
بصواريخ بعيده المدى لاصابه الخطوط
الخلفيه الروسيه واستعاده مزيد من الاراضي
هل من استجابه اعلنت الحكومه النرويجيه
ومجموعه كونسبرغ للدفاع والفضاء انهما
ستزودان اوكرانيا بمنظومات جديده مضاده
للطائرات المسيره بتمويل من حلفاء كياف
لتعزيز دفاعاتها ضد هذه الاسلحه التي
تستخدمها روسيا بكثافه وقبل ساعات اعلنت
الولايات المتحده انها سترسل الى اوكرانيا
مساعدات امنيه جديده بقيمه 200 مليون
دولار تتضمن ذخائر الدفاع الجوي ومدفعيه
وعتاد مضاده للمدرعات واجهزه اضافيه لدعم
جهود ازاله الالغام في المقابل وبعد اعداد
كياف للعمليات على مدى اشهر وجمع الوارد
وتدريب الجنود كانت القوات الروسيه تعزز
دفاعاتها ما يجعل من الصعب على الجيش
الاوكراني تحقيق تقدم سريع يردد المسؤولون
الروس في طلعتهم الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين ان
الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد فشل كما تواصل
روسيا حمله القصف على اوكرانيا مؤكده انها
تدمر مستودعات ومراكز عسكريه لنفهم الوضع
اكثر على الجبهات ينضم الينا من عمان
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللواء الدويري ماذا تفهم من
زياده وتيره استخدام المسيرات خاصه من قبل
اوكرانيا
لا هذه مسار موازي لمسار العمليات
العسكريه البريه بعد تعثر الهجوم المضاد
الذي تم الحديث مطولا عنه وتم الاعداد له
تم تاخير ساعه الصفر او ساعه البدء
لاسابيع ولعده مرات
وكان الجميع يتوقع او الغالبيه العظمى ان
هذه العمليات ستثير بالمقاربه الغربيه او
حسب العقائد القتاليه الغربيه والتي طبقت
في منطقه خاركيف في منتصف عام 2022 ولكن
كان هناك واقع مختلف جدا من حيث شبكات
التحصينات والخطوط الدفاعيه وبالتالي لم
يحقق المعمول لا بل تم الحديث ان ما جرى
ويجري حتى هذه اللحظه هي المرحله
التمهيديه وان الجهد الرئيسي لم يتم زجه
بعد ذلك جاء اله على جسر كرش وتزامنا مع
انتهاء اتفاقيات الحبوب وهنا سلكت
اوكرانيا او القوات الاوكرانيه مسارا
موازيا لادامه
الحديث عن الحرب والحاجي الى الاسلحه
ولفرد شروط معينه فبدات باستخدام الطائرات
المسيره
هذا المسار المواسي الى اي حد يزعج روسيا
عسكريا
عسكريا الازعاج محدود ولكن الازعاج في
الابعاد الاخرى السياسيه الاقتصاديه
الاجتماعيه لانه الان الشعب الروسي حتى
موسكو لا اقول بالمطلق بدا يشعر انه ضمن
منطقه عمليه وبالتالي لها ردودها ولا
تكلفتها وفاتوره التكاليف لكن كانجاز
عسكري قد يكون في منطقه شبه جزيره القرم
اكثر تاثيرا ونجاعه وفاعليه عندما تهاجم
الجسور الرئيسيه من شبه جزيره القرم الى
خرسون او لجسر كيرش الذي يتصل مع البر
الروسي وتؤثر على طرق الامداد تهاجم الى
غير ذلك نعم هناك تلقي بظلالها العسكري
الزوارق البحريه
دمرت او عصابه او اعطبت سفينه انزال
وناقله نفط هذا التاثير العسكري تقريبا
يظهر جليا في شبه جزيره القرم وليس داخل
روسيا طيب
حتى الان لا تبدو روسيا بانها تستطيع
مواجهه هذا الكن من المسيرات
هل تستطيع ان تطبع مع هذا الواقع روسيا اي
ان تبقى عرضه لاستهداف مسيرات في العمق
الروسي وفي شبه جزيره القرم
يعني
الامن المطلق غير لا يمكن تحقيقه وغير
موجود وعليها ان تتعايش وعليها ان تحدد
نقاط الضعف وعليها ان تطور تقنيات
المواجهه اما ان نقول ان دوله ما سوار
روسيا او غيرها لا يمكن لها ان تحقق الامد
المطلق وسيتم اختراق امنها وستصل الطائرات
المسيره لانه هناك عوامل كثيره تساعد على
هذا الاختراق سواء انواع الطائرات
قابله للتخفي غير قابله على خطوط الطيران
الارتفاع الحجم يعني امور كثيره جدا ندخل
في تفصيلات فنيه وبالتالي لكن نلاحظ ان
روسيا تتحدث في معظم الحالات عن النجاحات
كبيره في اسقاط هذه الطائرات لكن دعني
اوصف الحرب الروسيه خلال 18 شهر يعني
اتذكر المثل في بلاد الشام حسابات
الحقل والبيدر لم لا يمكن ان يتطابقوا
لماذا لان الامكانات التي تم حشدها
والوسائل التي تم اعتمادها والاهداف التي
يتم تحقيقها الوسائل والامكانات لا ترقى
لمستوى الاهداف سواف العمليه العسكريه
الروسي الخاص شكرا او في الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني الوافدواري في عمان شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
ازيد من زوارق المهاجرين نتابع اعلانا هنا
وهناك عن اتفاقات واجراءات امنيه وخطط
استباقيه لكن النزيف يستمر والماساه
تتواصل في احدث حلقاتها اعلن رسميا في
تونس عن مقتل احد عشر من طالبي اللجوء
وفقدان سبعه وانقاذ 23 بعد انقلاب قارب
قباله ساحل مدينه صفاقس التونسيه بحسب
المعلومات المتوفره كان على متن القارب 35
شخصا من بينهم نساء واطفال اغلبهم تونسيون
مع امكانيه وجود عدد قليل من افرقه جنوب
الصحراء تظهر ارقام جمعتها الامم المتحده
ان اكثر من 1800 شخص لقوا حتفهم منذ يناير
الماضي فقط في غرق قوارب في البحر المتوسط
الذي يعد اخطر مسار للهجره في العالم وهو
رقم يكاد يناهز ضعف العدد الذي سجل العام
الماضي هي اخبار مؤسفه لا نتمنى ان نحملها
في ختام الحصاد لكنه واقع العالم الذي
نعيش فيه ونامل ان يتغير نهايه الحصاه
شكرا للمتابعه الى اللقاء بامر الله
ورعايته
[موسيقى]